turns out your competition for the
seasons hottest toy may not be another
parent but a piece of computer code so
called cyber BOTS or scooping up some of
the season's most coveted items so that
unscrupulous sellers can then unload
them at much higher prices here to talk
about these Grinch BOTS is Derrick
Thompson senior editor at the Atlantic
Derrick this is pure evil this is one
longs for the housing days when moms and
dads would fight each other
yeah the toys fight that was human
versus human versus no no this is not a
winnable war they have a clear
technological advantage and to be clear
when we say bog what we're talking about
is a software robot and these are
software algorithms essentially programs
that go around the internet and buy up
products really really quickly much
faster than any human being could
possibly do typically we're used to
seeing these in the ticket markets yes
it was a u2 concert I believe in New
York several years ago where bots bought
1,000 tickets in one minute and then
resold them on eBay or you know on some
other site and what they're doing now
essentially is buying relatively cheap
toys 14 dollars for say something like a
fingerling and then reselling it on
Amazon or Ebay for up to $1,000 this is
essentially ransoming we will discuss
ransom of fingerling we'll discuss in a
different segment the parents who would
pay that kind of thing but I mean the
problem here is I mean well you know how
do you how do you come back this so the
short answer is it's extremely difficult
to combat it the slightly longer answer
is that there are certain rules you can
put in but a lot of these rules can be
sort of superseded by the technology so
for example you can put in quantity
limits you can check that only one eye
one IP address one human being
theoretically can only buy a certain
number of these toys the problem is that
these cyber scammers are just creating a
bunch of different IP addresses right so
that they can buy hundreds of these toys
all at once completely soak up the
supply of these toys I mean you look at
some of the most popular toys the season
on Toys R Us at Target at Walmart
they're sold out but then you go to eBay
Amazon and they're marked up by a
thousand person so the Internet
may not be able to stop the bots from
proliferating but can we can maybe sort
of punished on the back end I know that
Chuck Schumer has introduced something
called the better online ticket sales
act and that was to stop the online
ticket scalping can that be retrofitted
for these cyber by these Grinch box yes
the good news is that it can be amended
you can change the law and essentially
say the same way that we are going to
treat as criminal activity the bulk
purchasing of tickets for you to
concerts and Bruce concerts we can do
the exact same thing for toys the bad
news is that we all know how quickly the
Senate works it works the snail's pace
they've essentially said there's no way
that we can get this law through before
Christmas and so even if this is a law
that's going into effect it won't be in
effect for another 12 months in which
case the bots might be even more
sophisticated right get a read Charles
Dickens nightmare yes yes is the Grinch
box how do the toy makers and say Amazon
and companies like that feel about this
well so it's difficult because eBay and
Amazon are going to say we're open
marketplaces yes right our job as a
platform is essentially to make sure
that there is legal buying and selling
and these are legal toys even though
they're being marked up as you can see
on your screen right now by like 2,000
percent I do think that an enormous part
of this problem comes down to a huge
thing of 2017 which has been the dark
side of platform technology yeah you see
it with uber you see it with Facebook
and now you're seeing it with retail
markets as well so in information
markets transportation markets and
retail markets we're seeing the same
story which is that these platforms that
are amazingly successful at bringing
down prices and making it easier for
consumers to get into the market also
have the dark side that because you're
taking humans out of these marketplaces
there's less oversight and so bad actors
can basically do whatever they want
bring the humans back to the market
indeed bring them back bring mom and dad
back fighting fur in a safe way right
exactly a safe way orange how the grinch
BOTS stole Christmas that's a different
show all right Derek Thompson thanks